AS OF NOW, SHELLEY LUTHER
REMAINS BEHIND BARS.
LAURA.
SPENDING SO MUCH.
JOINING ME NOW IS THE EFFORT
MENTIONED TEXAS ATTORNEY GENERAL
ATTORNEY GENERAL.
KEN, IT’S GREAT TO SEE YOU.
YOU WANT THIS SALON OWNER OUT OF
JAIL, HOW ARE YOU GOING TO MAKE
THAT HAPPEN?
SWEETIE WAS A COMPLICATED
QUESTION.
WERE OPERATING UNDER A DIFFERENT
REGIME THAT WE’VE OPERATED
BEFORE.
THAT JUDGE, SHE WAS HELD IN
CONTEMPT.
THE GOVERNOR CAN ACTUALLY PARDON
THAT.
THOUGH IT’S REALLY PUBLIC
PRESSURE.
WE CAN’T GET AN APPEAL IN TIME,
SHE’S ONLY GOING TO BE THERE
SEVEN DAYS.
PUBLIC PRESSURE, AND SHOWS LIKE
THIS CAN HIGHLIGHT THE
INJUSTICE.
>> Laura: OTHER INDIVIDUALS
WHO ARE TRYING TO SAVE THEIR
LIVES.
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT SOMETHING
YOU’VE DEVOTED YEARS TO BUILDING
BUILDING, THAT IS THEIR LIVES.
IT’S EVERYTHING THAT THEY
DREAMED OF, EVERYTHING THAT THEY
WORKED FOR.
AT THEIR BLOOD, SWEAT, AND
TEARS.
IN A WAY, I SAW SOMEONE SAY
ONLINE, SHE’S FIGHTING FOR HER
LIFE.
BUT FOR THAT, THEY’RE PUTTING
HER IN JAIL.
>> YOU COULDN’T OF SAID IT ANY
BETTER.
I HAVE MY OWN BUSINESS, YOU HAVE
RENT PASTE TO
PAYMENTS.
THIS IS A WOMAN THAT HAS
EXPENSES, SHE HAS CHILDREN, AND
HERE SHE IS, SHE CAN OPERATE.
ALL SHE’S DONE -- HE HASN’T SOLD
DRUGS, SHE HASN’T HURT ANYBODY,
SHE HASN’T KILLED ANYBODY, AND
YET, THEY’RE RELISTING PRISONERS
AND DALLAS AND THEY’RE PUTTING
HER IN JAIL.
>> Laura: THEY’VE RELEASED
ABOUT 1,000 INMATES, THEY FLAT
OVER 370 WALK FREE.
SOME OF THEM FOR I.D. FRAUD,
BREAKING INTO A CAR, ANOTHER
PRISONER SET FREE IS NOW CHARGED
OF BEATING HIS EX-GIRLFRIEND,
THROWING HER GRANDMOTHER TO THE
GROUND.
HOW IS THIS THAT THESE PEOPLE
ARE BEING SET FREE WHILE PEOPLE
JUST WANT TO PUT FOOD ON THE
TABLE ARE BEING LOCKED UP?
IT’S CRAZY.
I CAN’T BELIEVE THIS IS AMERICA
SOMETIMES.
I CAN’T BELIEVE THIS IS TEXAS.
>> Ken: NO.
IT FEELS MORE LIKE CHINA THAN
AMERICA, AND LET IT ALONE
HAPPENING IN TEXAS.
IF THIS WHAT YOU SAID.
WE’VE GOT THE STATEMENT FROM THE
CLINTON ADMINISTRATION, DON’T
LET A GOOD CRISIS GET AWAY.
THIS IS CERTAINLY HAPPENING
HERE, THEY’RE RELEASING
POTENTIALLY THOUSANDS OF
CONVICTED FELONS BECAUSE THEY’RE
WORRIED ABOUT THEM GETTING THIS
VIRUS.
FOR SOME REASON THEY’RE NOT
WORRIED ABOUT HER, A WOMAN
THAT’S JUST TRYING TO DO HER JOB
JOB.
IF YOU WANT TO HAVE TO SAY THAT
I’VE BEEN LISTENING TO A LOT OF
THE ELITES CRITICISM OF BOTH
TEXAS AND FLORIDA.
IT’S THE RED STATE THAT THEY’RE
HITTING HARDEST YEAR.
DESPITE THE FACT THAT TEXAS HAS
A RELATIVELY FEW COVID-19 DOES.
WE DON’T WANT ANYONE TO DIE TO
FROM IT, BUT COMPARISON TO
NEW YORK OR NEW JERSEY, PER
HUNDRED THOUSAND, PER MILLION IS
ONE FRACTION
FLORIDA HAS ALSO HAD AN
EXEMPLARY RECORD, BUT THEY ARE
JUST SPLASHING AT TEXAS.
YOU GUYS ARE OUT THERE JUST
KILLING PEOPLE.
>> Ken: IT MAKES NO SENSE AT
ALL.
WE’VE DONE OUR BEST TO DEVELOP A
PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAVE LIVES.
BY ALLOWING PEOPLE SOME
SEMBLANCE OF THEIR LIVES,
ALLOWING THEM TO MAKE A LIVING,
HOW IS THAT WRONG?
I LITERALLY DON’T GET IT.
>> Laura: ATTORNEY GENERAL
PAXTON, WE’RE GOING TO BE